[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
yakarta la capital de Indonesia donde
viven más de 11 millones de personas se
hunde bajo el nivel del mar a una
velocidad alarmante una catástrofe
anunciada que llevó al gobierno
indonesio a tomar una decisión radical
trasladar su capital a más de 1500
kilómetros y crear una nueva ciudad
desde cero en la isla de borneo la nueva
capital que debería estar terminada en
2045 es una amenaza adicional para el
ecosistema de La Isla que ya es muy
frágil la consecuencia principal de la
creación de esta nueva ciudad es la
deforestación decenas de especies como
el orangután símbolo de Indonesia están
en peligro de extinción los cultivos
intensivos de aceite de Palma han
diezmado progresivamente su hábitat en
toda la isla de borneo Lucy y Ulises
cayó viajaron a Indonesia y nos cuenta n
en el siguiente reportaje las razones y
los desafíos detrás de esta decisión
inédita
[Música]
Este muro se para mi barrio del mar
Si no existiera el agua inundaría todas
nuestras casas
mi objetivo es poder irme de yakarta con
mi familia para instalarnos en un sitio
más alto pero por ahora no tengo los
medios para hacerlo
Aunque somos muy conscientes de que
yakarta se está hundiendo
la vida de mujama tronie depende de Este
muro de 5 metros de alto y 32 kilómetros
de largo que evita que los barrios
pobres del norte de yakarta sean
engullidos por el océano
porque la capital Indonesia de 11
millones de habitantes construida sobre
un Delta hoy en día sufre directamente
las consecuencias de la subida del nivel
de las aguas y se hunde poco a poco una
situación con consecuencias dramáticas
sobre todo en época de monzones cuando
caen lluvias torrenciales en la ciudad
[Aplausos]
toda la ciudad de yakarta está
preocupada por estas inundaciones que
trastornan la vida de los habitantes en
el centro Pero sobre todo en las zonas
costeras porque aquí el suelo se ha
hundido peligrosamente por debajo del
nivel del mar y sigue bajando 25
centímetros cada año a lo largo de la
costa un naufragio que se explica por
las décadas dedicadas a extraer el agua
directamente de los acuíferos
subterráneos
debilitados por la perforación de los
miles de pozos los suelos ya no pueden
sostener el peso de la ciudad
en este Barrio Pobre de 10.000
habitantes
en medio de un laberinto de callejuelas
que conoce como la palma de su mano
vamos a ver
vengan por aquí es un atajo para llegar
hasta el muro
con 49 años fue uno de los primeros
testigos de la subida de las aguas en
yakarta ahora este hijo del barrio A
duras penas reconoce la llanura donde
creció
muchos de los sitios a los que iba a
jugar cuando era niño han desaparecido
desde la construcción del muro y las
tierras que hay del otro lado ya fueron
engullidas por el océano
muham Rony sabe que el tiempo está
contado
porque la presa construida hace cinco
años ya da muestras de debilidad
a lo largo del muro hay grietas que los
habitantes han tratado de reparar en
vano poco a poco el agua ha ido ganando
terreno
más a la INE al principio no había
grietas aparecieron unos meses después y
el agua se empezó a filtrar por ahí
con los habitantes de los alrededores
nos preocupamos cuando vemos el estado
del muro pensamos que puede ceder en
cualquier momento por la presión del
océano y todo el barrio quedaría
inundado eso nos da mucho miedo
ante el deterioro de la situación en
yakarta las autoridades indonesias
tomaron una decisión radical e inédita
construir una nueva capital desde cero
aquí en la isla de borneo El pulmón
verde de Indonesia a 1500 kilómetros de
yakarta
la obra ya empezó oficialmente sólo se
destruirán selvas que actualmente son
destinadas a la Industria del papel
22.000 obreros trabajan desde hace meses
en este proyecto titánico valorado en 30
mil millones de dólares del que se
enorgullece este responsable encargado
de supervisar los trabajos
comunión la región tiene pocos riesgos
de ser afectada por catástrofes
naturales
hay pocos seísmos o inundaciones A
diferencia de
yakartang como los recursos naturales
son muy abundantes Aquí también es una
buena oportunidad de desarrollo para la
región Así es como debería verse la
futura capital una ciudad con Aires
futuristas con muchas zonas verdes que
promueve las energías renovables será la
sede del palacio presidencial y se prevé
que haya cerca de dos millones de
habitantes para 2035 principalmente
funcionarios del estado
esta ciudad ya tiene un nombre nos
Antara que significa archipiélago en
indonesio una palabra que debe
simbolizar la unidad del país
[Música]
pero para edificar de la nada esta nueva
capital verde miles de habitantes
indígenas deberán ser expulsados
miren
aquí Ya empezaron a construir edificios
oficiales
ya nació en esta región cada día Observa
el avance de las obras y no soporta la
idea de saber que la nueva capital
invadirá estas tierras vivimos aquí
desde hace mucho tiempo cuando todavía
no había carreteras y había que cruzar
los ríos para moverse
cuando nuestros pueblos no tenían
electricidad
y ahora nos quieren echar para que los
nuevos habitantes tengan espacio
al lado de este pueblo se está
construyendo un sistema de recolección
de agua para abastecer la futura capital
Esta es la presa que están construyendo
está muy cerca de este pueblo
tradicional pues Abraham andan
como la obra está tan solo a unos metros
de las viviendas 80 familias serán
expulsadas y reubicadas a 200 kilómetros
de aquí obligadas a abandonar sus
tierras y sus raíces
no es la única indignada por el proyecto
aquí el descontento Es evidente los
habitantes veían en la nueva capital una
oportunidad de desarrollo y de empleo
pero ahora obligados a desalojar se
sienten totalmente imponentes
nuestras tierras son lo único que
tenemos van a destruir nuestros cultivos
y nuestras casas A dónde vamos a ir Cómo
será la vida de nuestros hijos y de
nuestros nietos
no podemos hacer nada Lo siento mucho
pero esta capital no nos hace sentir
orgullosos ni felices al contrario nos
pone tristes y ansiosos
no nos oponemos al gobierno nosotros los
indígenas no queremos luchar contra el
gobierno
simplemente queremos que nos escuchen
el borneo el proyecto de la futura
capital también preocupa a los
defensores del medio ambiente
a causa de la explotación de aceite de
Palma los bosques ya son Víctimas de la
deforestación y decenas de especies como
el orangután símbolo de Indonesia están
en peligro de extinción los cultivos
intensivos de aceite de Palma anti
diezmado progresivamente su hábitat en
toda la isla de borneo la nueva capital
es una amenaza adicional para el
ecosistema de La Isla que ya es muy
frágil
a 50 kilómetros de las obras Agus
protege este manglar desde hace 23 años
en los últimos años ante la expansión
urbana ha visto disminuir su superficie
poco a poco y teme que el fenómeno se
acelere con la nueva capital
aquí había un manglar
ahora está destruido es un puerto para
el transporte marítimo
amor preservar estos bloques es
fundamental porque albergan especies
endémicas que sólo existen en la isla de
borneo miren allá están
es un grupo de monos narigudos
en la región sólo quedarían 150 de estos
monos de nariz prominente y su cantidad
no ha dejado de disminuir en los últimos
años
acusbei teme que su hábitat se reduzca
aún más con la llegada masiva de nuevos
habitantes
el riesgo es que con la fuerte presión
inmobiliaria los manglares se han
destruidos y transformados en
infraestructuras
eso puede reducir drásticamente la
superficie de la selva
Y si los monos narigudos ya no
encuentran alimentos
la especie va a desaparecer
esta nueva capital que debe brotar en
medio de la selva los habitantes de los
barrios pobres de yakarta no la verán
nunca
muham y sabe que no hará parte de las
personas reubicadas
[Música]
en su casa donde tiene una pequeña
tienda vive constantemente Bajo La
amenaza de las inundaciones para reducir
el riesgo tuvo que adaptarse
aquí el suelo estaba más o menos 80
centímetros más abajo cuando ocurrieron
las inundaciones y subir todo el nivel
de su casa ya se han elevado unas 20
casas en el barrio
pero el Padre de Familia sabe que la
amenaza persiste a pesar de esta reforma
en época de monzones su casa todavía se
inunda todavía tengo miedo de las
inundaciones sobre todo Si el muro cede
si las grietas se siguen agrandando
nuestro miedo podría volverse realidad
el barrio podría quedar sumergido en muy
poco tiempo
[Música]
en el norte de yakarta una parte de este
barrio ya quedó inundada como esta
mezquita lentamente devorada por las
aguas
vaya nulo
antes estaba feliz por vivir a la orilla
del mar ver las olas y divertirme en el
agua pero desde que vi ese muro
y la subida de las aguas entendí que mi
vida depende de esa Barrera
[Música]
ahora creo que ya no podemos seguir
viviendo aquí porque el nivel del agua
aumenta constantemente
lo único que podemos hacer es tomar
algunas precauciones y esperar que el
gobierno se encargue del problema
la nueva capital Indonesia debería estar
terminada en 2045 para ese momento un
tercio de yakarta podría estar bajo el
agua
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
Recuerda que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web
trans24.com hasta la próxima
[Música]